wie heißt du
ich heiße angelo mein name ist rosi ich
heiße juli
ich heiße david ich heiße im juli
ich heiße louis ich heiße ari das
trackpad stern
ich heiße eleni ich heiße paul ii ich
heiße woher kommst du ich komme erst
ziemlich ich komme aus der schweiz
ich komme aus frankreich ich bin halb
mexikaner und halb deutsche ich bin halb
mexikaner und halb deutsche ich komme
aus münchen
es kam aus berlin ich auch ich komme aus
berlin und mitarbeiter nicht hier
geboren und sondern ich komme aus
thüringen ich komme aus berlin
ich kam aus köln
aus deutschland wo lebst du
ich lebe in zürich momentan lebe ich in
zürich
ich lebe in berlin ich wohne in berlin
charlottenburg
ich lebe hier in berlin charlottenburg
ich wohne in berlin ich lebe in berlin
werden in wetter ich liebe berlin mitte
und in kreuzberg ich lebe in brandenburg
ich wohne in berlin
lieber in berlin was ist dein beruf das
ist schwierig ich bin gastronom
ich schneide filme ich gehe noch zur
schule
ich gehe zur schule und macht zurzeit ab
ich bin student wir sind schüler
ich bin ein lehrer was lernen sie
geschichte und geografie
ich habe gerade meine schule
abgeschlossen ich studiere ich bin
arbeite in der it was ist dein hobby
ich gehe gerne verfahren meine hobbys
dem zeichnen fahrradfahren und schwimmen
bier trinken
ich reise gerne und ich lese gerne und
ich trinke gerne kaffee meine hobbys
sind theater spielen malen zeichnen
klettern oder anderen sport ich spiele
gerne fußball macht gern sport wie
klettern joggen gehen und lese noch
gerne darf mich mit freunden
meine hobbys sind kochen musik machen
reisen also was in der freizeit machen
draußen sein mit freunden treffen
oh das ist schwer fahrradfahren
schwimmen lesen mein hobby ist sich mit
freunden zu treffen und das leben zu
genießen
dies schließe gern schwimmen gern die
gern ins kino
das war ein video für menschen die
gerade anfangen deutsch zu lernen
in den nächsten wochen werden wir noch
viele weitere solche videos produzieren
die für a1 und a2 niveau gedacht sind
wenn ihr zu diesem video noch
interaktive übungen machen wollt dann
werdet einen patchen von easy german
dann bekommt ihr jede woche übungen zu
unseren videos lernt das vokabular die
ausdrücke und die grammatik
hier könnt ihr sie german abonnieren bis
bald